hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on monster on a world again
and today we're gonna be doing another
one of the solo guides but today we're
gonna be tackling Glavin is my
personally my favorite monster and
monster hunter world ice-born I think
Glavin this is [ __ ] beautiful and I
really wish I played some of the older
games so I could end up fighting him
myself back in the older games but
goddamn do I love this monster anyway
let's get right into today's video as
always like to be if we do enjoy
subscribe if you're new let's get
started so for the physiology report as
usual he has a three star weakness to
water and a 2 star weakness to ice he's
resistant to fire and can inflict the
fire blood side if we stay within the
fire weapons and I used a rarity 10 at
dura totus dual blades which just came
up because of the mastering ice-born
stuff and they were super well for me
for Mantle's I definitely recommend
fireproof temporal or Rocksteady
especially the fireproof that's going to
be helping a lot because they're going
to be smoking you with a lot of fire
moves head is definitely the most
weakest point he has but you can of
course go for the tail from you to sever
for parts or any other place that you
might need to hit him Glavine is though
is definitely the most notorious because
of his giant tail a huge tail that he
can light on fire just by teething on it
if you are fighting in the middle of the
wide spire waist you can during the
story you can use the screamer pods to
send him to the sand hole I didn't
actually do this I guess one of the
creatures of the endemic life throughout
the area did it for me I was thinking
about doing it but I completely forgot
but we still got sent through the hole
anyway and then I had a really nice
little turf war with him in Diablos
another quick tip is to try to use the
clutch claws as much as possible a
couple hits and you should be able to
make a weak spot out of his head but
just to make sure that he's in in the
middle of doing a move while you do
because if you do it before even will
try to knock you off and you're gonna be
losing unnecessary health that you don't
need to lose when this can do multiple
things with this tail he can slash down
on top of you with one of them as well
as slash you with it the slash does
loads of damage so watch out for that
and if you're hit by it it will also
cause you to take fire boy if it's lit
on fire the top-down swing is pretty
easy to dodge but it usually comes with
a second one right after so if you're
careful you might get hit with the
second and not the first and if you get
hit by both that's pretty much instant
death right there so if you do get hit
by the first one definitely stay down
let the iframes help you or if you dodge
the first hole and watch out for the
second sometimes he does sometimes he
doesn't it's usually kind of up in the
air of when he does I've noticed that
sometimes when he's enraged she does it
more frequently but there really isn't a
specific definite answer for it just
when he does do that top down swing
definitely watch for the second slash
and of course also don't miss charge
where you're gonna be sitting on him
multiple times I've been misjudging if
he's gonna hit me or not because I
obviously don't want to dodge when I
don't need to because then that could be
free hits that I could be missing and
ends up still hitting me because his
tail is incredibly huge so definitely
watch out on the range for that and
don't misjudge it he can also bite his
tail to either do a large swing that
could almost warn shot if not always
warned shot you or also charge his mouth
with a fireball blast the people usually
keep into his mouth if he's not using it
dodging run away from the fireball that
one's pretty obvious to do obviously if
you do get hit you're gonna be beginning
fire boy but you even get rid of that by
dodging three times or by having twenty
fire resistance for any type of armor
that you have in total because that will
get rid of blights
entirely that same goes for ice thunder
and all those different types but for
the slash I would definitely be careful
when where you're gonna be if he's
charging up and you're really close to
him then definitely stay underneath his
belly if you're a bit far away I would
probably stay far away and if you're
kind of in that middle ground to choose
one and stick to it don't go one and
then go back because and you're gonna
get hit you got to commit to whatever
you're doing as for the stuff around the
area that Gajuwaka may help you the sand
dune in the back helps a lot and there's
a lot of mounting spots that you can use
to surprise him so that's always nice
and of course the occasional turf war
just to get that extra damage you didn't
need to do because the monsters like to
fight each other
other than that Glavine is releasing
that top of a fight he can do a lot of
damage so definitely make sure to get
some fire resistant armor I believe at
that point there might be some monsters
who will give you some fire resistance
stuff I don't actually remember a
specific monster that's in master rink
but worst case worst comes to worst you
might just have to farm somebody that
has a high-ranked type of armor because
maybe you're not there yet but also I
found out that sometimes even if you
just go to the SOS for joining a quest
some people will be fighting you can
obviously go to a master rank engine F
some people are probably gonna be doing
investigations an optional quest with
just the regular Anjanette and you can
just farm him for that extra gear if you
really need to it shouldn't be that big
of a deal as usual if you have any other
questions leave them in the comments
below and if you have any other details
that I may have missed out on or I got
something wrong that needs to be
corrected for the video leave it down in
the comments down below I don't make a
giant pin comment with all your guys in
was that nobody has to scour through
hundreds and hundreds of comments or
whatever it happens to be you just go to
the very top comment and look at it
yourself so I always think as for all
that information it cuz like I said I'm
always one I'm just one guy I don't have
the experiences that you're experiencing
we might have different things or maybe
there was some move that he didn't throw
out in the thirty minutes that I fought
him that I have never seen but you've
seen tons of times so that's why we do
those things
hey guys like the V if you do enjoy
subscribe if you're new I covered the
solo guides a monster hunter world
whether that be to progress people
through the story or if they want to get
through the farming and get those extra
bits of armor and weapons that they
might need for an upcoming fight or
maybe just for a fashion statement I
totally understand that's why I'm here
well if you guys did enjoy that and if
you did definitely leave a like I mean
that guys take care have a great
yesterday and draw the rest of the
ice-born story you're gonna be going on
to a very formidable enemy right after
this quest and I thought guys take care
peace out and enjoy
[Music]
you
[Music]